So what's really surprised you over the last five years in terms of how CUDA has developed
and how people have used it? And I'll throw one thing out there.
I think the day that I was disclosed on CUDA, right before it launched,
if you had asked me at the time I would have said,
"In 5 years, maybe people aren't going to be programming so much in CUDA."
"Instead people are going to build higher level languages on top of this,
and that's what we're going to be using."
But CUDA's really proven to have legs
and is a very efficient way to keep these machines busy with lots of work to do.
So I certainly would have lost a bet I made then.
What have been some of the things that have surprised you?
I think one of the things that surprised me the most is just the diversity of fields,
and really, you can't predict it in some regards but you can.
There are applications for computing in tons of spaces,
and we have a vision of if computation is free, what would that mean,
and what would it mean for everyone? And we can inspire ourselves.
But there are all these short-term things that we can go achieve with GPUs
that were simply just not--no one thought of.
There may be a small group of people out there that were researching them,
but by giving them this processor where computation is effectively free
and memory bandwidth is 10 to 100x faster than what you're used to,
they're just unleashed.
ASTRA GPU. There's an actual conference now on doing astronomy simulations with GPUs.
And they were one of the first people to jump on the bandwagon
because they have a really big problem.
They're trying to simulate galaxies and black holes and star formation, and they were just stuck.
The simulations were so hard and they'd maybe get to run it on a super computer
for a brief few cycles at a time.
But now all these guys are able to do their computing right at their desktop
and actually prove theory about how stars form, how a galaxy forms.
I mean, I think no one ever knew this kind of problem that existed
because this little community was off to themselves.
But we discovered these things, and we're so excited to see that we make a difference.